[Music]
they may not be as necessary to a
franchise as some others
but these sequels are definitely worth
watching
and if you haven't heard of them you
aren't alone
these are the best movie sequels you've
never watched few films have had an
impact as great as 1939's the wizard of
oz
adapted from l frank baum's novel the
wonderful wizard of
oz not only was the film representative
of the height of technology
but it confirmed judy garland as a
bonafide star
the wizard of oz was nominated for six
academy awards
including best picture and according to
the library of congress
it's been watched more than any other
movie
critically beloved it's a true american
classic that continues to have an impact
on audiences today
45 years later return to oz finds young
dorothy gail
now played by farouza balk on a new
adventure back to oz
only this trip is much much darker
gone are the friendly residents of
munchkinland
and the familiar faces that belong to
dorothy's yellow brick road companions
emerald city lies in ruins overrun by
the appropriately named wheelers
creatures with wheels for hands and
to feet that return to oz is a strange
second serving would be an
understatement
the movie has little to do with its
predecessor outside of its central
decidedly less musical heroine
it came in seventh at the box office its
opening weekend
bringing in less than 3 million on a 28
million dollar budget
critics were split with many noting its
darker tone as either
its most positive or most negative
attribute
still it's attracted a cult following in
the years since its release
and if a princess with a collection of
heads is more your speed than a wicked
witch with flying monkeys
return to waz is certainly a worthwhile
endeavor
brian de palma's 1976 horror classic
carry marked the first of many stephen
king adaptations
the story of teenage outcast carrie
white who discovers she has telekinetic
abilities to a murderous degree
carrie is generally regarded as one of
if not
the best of king's adaptations and it's
considered to be one of the greatest
horror films
ever made it's also gone on to inspire
two remakes and a sequel
decades after its initial release while
a remake of the horror classic should be
expected
a carry sequel is something that
requires a little more finesse
after all the original film ends with
the teenager's death
it doesn't get much more final than that
unless of course
carrie were to have a secret half-sister
with the exact same
untapped telekinetic potential which is
the general premise for 1999's the rage
kerry ii starring emily burgle as said
sibling rachel lang
the film follows the same general beats
as its predecessor
members of the in-crowd play the less
popular kid for laughs
she loses control of her abilities
everything
and everyone goes to hell the rage
couldn't impress critics or audiences
and its lasting legacy is as a
disposable relic of 90s era teen horror
but it's an entertaining watch if for no
other reason than the fact that it made
an attempt to expand on the original's
lore
as opposed to just rehashing it all
together and burgle is solid as rachel
who turns out to be a more sympathetic
character on account of having at least
some measure of social ability
1996's trainspotting was an instant hit
and a true encapsulation of 90s indie
cinema
the portrait of addiction and poverty in
suburban edinburgh
based on irvine welsh's same named novel
centers on a group of heroin addicted
friends led by mark renton
as they struggle with sobriety and
everyday existence
it spoke to an entire generation of lost
souls
and its unflinching portrayal of abuse
was highlighted by a dark humor
and an incredible soundtrack in 1999
the british film institute named
trainspotting the 10th best british film
of the century
two decades later the original cast
reunited with director danny boyle for
t2 trainspotting
which sees renton return to his old
neighborhood as
his marriage falls apart he suffers a
heart attack
and the impending doom of middle age
looms around the corner
choose facebook twitter snapchat
instagram and a thousand other ways to
spew your bile across people you've
never met
this go go-around renton and his pals
find themselves caught up in a legal
mess revolving around the operation of
an
illegal brothel although t2 performed
well internationally
it had a quiet opening in america
bringing in less than two hundred
thousand dollars its first
weekend still the film did well with
critics
who praised its emotionally resonant
portrayal of a group of people
struggling to move forward from their
past
mistakes it may not be as innovative as
its predecessor
but it still speaks to those who grew up
with the original
and may not yet have completely found
their way
in the realm of science fiction there is
perhaps no film more influential than
stanley kubrick's 1968 masterpiece
2001 a space odyssey set largely aboard
the jupiter-bound spacecraft discovery 1
2001 tells the story of a mysterious
monolith the group of astronauts sent to
investigate it
and the onboard computer system that
ultimately turns against them
the film was nominated for four academy
awards
winning one for best special visual
effects and is today regarded as one of
the most culturally significant films
ever made
it remains a topic of discussion for
film fans and scholars alike
peter hayam's 1984 follow-up 2010 the
year we make contact
was never going to be able to reach the
bar that 2001 had set
but it definitely tries nine years after
the discovery one incident
a joint u.s soviet mission is sent out
to uncover the truth
2010 further explores the presence and
meaning of the monolith
although like 2001 the audience is left
with more questions than answers about
its true purpose
2010 did fairly well at the box office
opening in second place with a seven
million dollar haul response from
critics was overall favorable
but its biggest problem isn't that it's
not a good sci-fi movie
it really is it's that it isn't a
stanley kubrick sci-fi movie
taken on its own merits 2010 turns out
to be one of the more enjoyable space
set films of the 80s
there is a benefit to following a film
that's never been considered a classic
or a masterpiece one that hasn't set any
box office or awards records
when expectations are low or
non-existent
you can really do anything you want
1978's attack of the killer tomatoes was
no
critical darling the film about a
country besieged by mutated carnivorous
tomatoes
and the team of specialists tasked with
saving the day
has received mostly negative reviews
over the years
in spite of this attack of the killer
tomatoes is a bonafide cult classic
that's launched an
entire franchise of sequels novels
video games and kids cartoons the
approach to its first sequel
1988's return of the killer tomatoes was
one of the
throw everything at the wall and see
what stick's variety
a decade after the great tomato war
tomatoes have been outlawed
everything seems to be going well until
professor mortimer gangrene
the never spoken of true villain behind
the film's first attack
figures out a way to reverse engineer
the music that brought about his initial
defeat to his favor
transforming tomatoes into human beings
our heroes in this installment are pizza
boy chad
tomato turned human tara chad's best
friend matt
and a poorly mutated tomato named ft
like its predecessor return of the
killer tomatoes
is completely ridiculous but where
attack of the killer tomatoes is just a
parody of bee movies
return of the killer tomatoes is a
parody of a parody
which somehow makes it a better film
from fourth wall breaking to unnecessary
product placement and fuzzy mutated pet
adventures
it's beyond anything in its genre which
is a good thing the star trek franchise
is vast and long running one that
follows multiple crews and which has
lasted more than half a century
since 1979 13 star trek films have been
made
although only three crews have made it
to the big screen
two if we're counting the jj abrams
alternate timeline one as
just a variation of the original
the film series has had its fair share
of ups and downs
and while one might assume an eighth
film would have a difficult time
standing up against some of its
predecessors
1996's star trek first contact
managed to take everyone by surprise
i bring order to chaos
the follow-up to 1994's generations
which effectively passed the motion
picture torch from kirk's enterprise to
picard's
first contact is the first of the star
trek films to focus solely
on the next generation crew it also
revisits one of its greatest storylines
the battle with the borg years after
picard's assimilation into an escape
from the collective
a new board threat sends the crew of the
enterprise back in time to save earth
from mass assimilation
first contact has been hailed as one of
the best films in the entire series
with critics praising both the film's
performances in its direction
which comes courtesy of number one
himself
jonathan frakes it's a truly interesting
updated take on the story and having a
big screen budget to tell it
definitely works to the film's benefit
by 2011 the world had grown weary of
sydney prescott and her seemingly
never-ending parade of obsessed
mask-wearing murderous psychos scream 3
which hit theaters in 2000 was panned by
critics
who claimed the film fell back on the
same old cliches the franchise had once
destroyed
still it managed to nearly make up for
its entire cost its first weekend at the
box office
so the studio system trudged forward
green lighting a fourth installment in
the franchise
hopes for greatness weren't exactly high
but scream 4 turned out to be more than
just a passable sequel
returning to its roots the film features
two
ghostface killers working in tandem jill
roberts
sydney's jealous fame-hungry cousin and
charlie walker jill's secret boyfriend
and horror movie aficionado
the rules however have changed in this
scream installment
we find the killers are adhering to
movie remake rules
modern audiences get savvy to the rules
of the originals so the reversals become
the new standard
it's a small change from the franchise's
original formula
but it's enough to make this particular
sequel stand out
having killer stars emma roberts and
rory culkin
inject some much needed fresh blood into
the franchise
is an added bonus their performances are
what ultimately makes the movie
and it's fun to check out robert's play
with villainy
prior to her memorable turn on american
horror story
coven when it hit theaters in 1978
no one suspected that john carpenter's
halloween
a low budget slasher about a boogie man
in a spray painted captain kirk mask
and mechanics overalls who stalks a
babysitter
and kills all her friends along the way
would become the phenomenon it did
the film set the stage for what much of
horror would go on to look like in the
following
years and since it's become not only a
classic
but required viewing for anyone even
remotely interested in the genre
michael myers is an icon and it's hard
to imagine the world of halloween movies
without him
but it wasn't always meant to be this
way carpenter's intention was to have
the michael myers story end with the
first film
after its success carpenter quote had to
write the sequel but as he explained to
the hollywood reporter in 2015
i thought that we were done with telling
stories about michael myers and the guy
in the mask
i thought there's not much more to say
so we thought we'd come up with a new
story
every year we could call it halloween
but it didn't have to do anything with
michael myers
and so in 1982 we got halloween 3
season of the witch a film that swaps
out michael myers for a piece of
stonehenge
and some cursed halloween masks and
which tells the story of one man's plot
to sacrifice a bunch of children
in order to bring about a new age of
witchcraft
halloween 3 may not have been a hit with
critics who'd expected another michael
myers installment
but it's since developed its own fanbase
one that doesn't
need a masked maniac at halloween
there's no denying the overwhelming
appeal of 1984's horror comedy gremlins
centered on a family who unwittingly
unleashes a horde of mischievous
monsters upon the
small town of kingston falls gremlins
combines holiday fantasy
with outright terror taking on a
consumer culture with a little water and
some sunlight
it proved to be a massive hit raking in
over 12
million dollars its opening weekend a
few years later
the cast and crew reunited and hoping to
strike gold twice
gremlins 2 the new batch hit theaters in
june of 1990
while the basic premise of the original
story is here
for the most part gremlins 2 is a movie
all its own
both films are horror comedies but
gremlins 2 takes the story in a more
lighthearted direction than its
predecessor
relying more on parody for laughs it's
over the top in its comedic excess
joe dante who directed both films told
bloody disgusting in 2015
that he never wanted to make a sequel
but was given
quote three times the money along with
the freedom to do whatever he wanted
he explained so i made gremlins 2 which
was essentially about how there didn't
need to be a sequel to gremlins
i can't believe this i mean this is
worse than the first one
we just show these movies madam we don't
make them
regardless of how it came to be gremlins
2 is one of those sequels that fans
should hold as near
and dear to their hearts as the original
even if it is just making fun of itself
the entire time
demonic possession has served as
hollywood horror fodder for decades
the most famous of these films is of
course 1973's the exorcist
william friedkin takes on william peter
blatty's 1971
novel that centers on reagan a young
girl who falls under the control of a
demon named
pazuzu and on father damian karis
a priest struggling with his faith who's
tasked with
saving her the film wound up being a hit
at the box office
raking in nearly 200 million dollars
domestically
and it became the first horror movie to
be nominated for best picture at the
academy awards obviously there was a
market for pazuzu
and in 1977 he and reagan
made a comeback with the exorcist 2 the
heretic
that film which attempted to expand upon
the demonic lore of the first with
psychic healers and doppelgangers was a
failure both critically
and financially but in 1990
blatty returned to the franchise serving
as both writer and director of the
exorcist 3.
ignoring the events of the heretic the
exorcist 3
follows william kinderman a police
lieutenant
investigating a series of deaths that
look like those committed by a now dead
serial killer
jason miller reprises his role as charis
who after having survived the reagan
exorcism
is now being used as a killer conduit
while not without its faults the
exorcist 3 is a vast
improvement on its predecessor it's
thoughtful
and both scott and miller are
exceptional in an unfortunate turn of
events however
blatty was forced to add an exorcism
sequence to the end
forever marring a film that would have
otherwise been a haunting and cerebral
follow-up worthy of his original
when wes cravens a nightmare on elm
street hit theaters in 1984
it was like nothing horror fans had ever
seen before
a killer targeting teens in their dreams
a community of adults behind a massive
cover-up
and a villain so terrifying that he kept
both the film's characters and its
audience
awake at night robert england built his
entire career around freddy krueger
a role he credits for making him quote
an international actor overnight
and since first donning that knifed
glove he's gone on to play the killer
seven more times as the franchise went
on however
it became a parody of itself and freddie
was relegated to little more than a
caricature
but craven always was the kind of writer
director who thrived on turning things
on their head
and like he did with the horror genre in
1984
he flipped the narrative of his original
masterpiece a decade later
with wes craven's new nightmare
reuniting original cast members as
real-life versions of themselves who
wind up terrorized by a demonic force
posing as freddy krueger
new nightmare has almost nothing to do
with the original nightmare on elm
street narrative
instead it examines the horror industry
itself
as well as the legacy of craven's
original film
and the franchise it created but the
problem comes when the story dies
and that can happen in a lot of ways it
can get too familiar to people or
somebody waters it down to make it an
easier sell
it's meta at its very best and it in
fact serves as a sort of warm-up to
craven's 1996 hit
scream the approach proved successful
with both critics and audiences
wes craven's new nightmare is considered
one of the best in the entire series
second only to the original
comedies in the early aughts were often
over the top
raunchy and ridiculous stoner comedies
which were exceptionally popular at the
time
were all of these things but with an
added layer of unlikely drug-induced
hijinks
enter harold and kumar go to white
castle
a 2004 film that follows the titular
characters on a pot fueled quest to
satiate their late night munchies
the pair are thrust into a series of
misadventures but ultimately find their
way
thanks in part to neil patrick harris
while not an oscar contender by any
means
harold and kumar go to white castle
receive generally favorable reviews upon
its release
mostly on account of its likable leads
and edgy humor
although its 2008 follow-up harold and
kumar
escape from guantanamo bay was decidedly
less successful john cho and cal penn
reunited once more in 2011
for a very harold and kumar christmas a
3d holiday film that revisits the duo
two years after having gone their
separate ways
like the films that came before it a
very harold and kumar christmas tends
toward
lowbrow humor but not at all to the
extent that guantanamo bay did
instead christmas leans into the holiday
spirit
tempering its crass comedy with genuine
feel-good moments
that isn't to say that it will ever
become a holiday classic
but it's an entertaining final
installment to a franchise that
understood when it was time to say
goodbye
there's much to be said for robert
zemeckis 1985 time travel comedy back to
the future
telling the story of high schooler marty
mcfly who
with the help of inventor doc brown
travels back in time to save his parents
marriage and his future existence
back to the future is to this day one of
the most beloved
and original movies ever made it was
both a critical
and financial success going on to become
the highest grossing film of 1985.
it was nominated for four academy awards
including best screenplay
and the new york times lists it as one
of the best 1 000 movies ever made
there are two sequels and while 1989's
back to the future part 2 is the one
that's remembered most by fans
it's back to the future part 3 that's
the forgotten gem of the franchise
after learning of doc's death in 1885 at
the hands of bill tannen's great
grandfather mad dog
marty travels back to the old west in
order to save him
part three has a much simpler narrative
than part two
but it's helped along with a fun and
interesting setting
a locomotive time machine and a love
interest for doc
that quite frankly was well deserved the
film was also a bigger hit with critics
than the prior installment
with the general consensus being that
its paring down of plot elements
worked in its favor it may not be the
cultural powerhouse that the original is
but it definitely keeps from falling
into the franchise trap
of unworthy sequels check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]